غضب عارم لا يتوقف في ايران فاتظاهرات
التي تلت مقتل شابه الكرديه مهسا اميني
بعد توقيفها من قبل شرطه الاخلاق لا تهدا
بل تتوسعوا من مدينه لاخرى
الغضب الشعبي زاد من تاجره تدهور الاقتصاد
مما ادى الانقطاع الخدمات الاساسيه وندره
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه في الريال
الايراني سجل انهيار ملحوظا مقابل الدولار
كما تجاوز معدل التضخم في ايران ثمانيه
واربعين في المئه في شهر سبتمبر الماضي
وهي نسبه الاعلى منذ العام 1995
ورغم التاثيرات السلبيه التي على منها
الاقتصاد الايراني منذ انسحاب الرئيس
الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب من الاتفاق
النووي وما نجم عنه من عوده العقوبات على
ايران
الا ان اقتصاديين وخبراء في الشان
الايراني يحملون مسؤوليه التدهور في
المقام الاول لسوء الاداره الاقتصاديه
للنظام
النظام الايراني بات محاصرا اذا بين ازمه
داخليه متفاقمه يعجز عن قمعها وازمه
اقتصاديه قد تؤدي الى زياده الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه وخروجها عن نطاق السيطره